le vote de confiance merci beaucoup la
première ministre ne sollicitera pas la
confiance des parlementaires il y aura
une discussion une déclaration de
politique générale suivie de débat à
l'Assemblée nationale mercredi à 15h et
puis en soirée au Sénat s'envote alors
c'est pas une première c'était le cas où
Raymond Barre Georges Pompidou Edith
Cresson c'était le cas aussi avec Michel
Rocca ou Pierre Bérégovoy je dis que
c'est pas une première la confiance ne
se décrète pas a priori elle se
construit patiemment texte à prétexte
nous sommes en mesure le sol d'ailleurs
parti en mesure d'avoir une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale je le redis aucune
opposition ne peut même enseignant avec
une autre opposition disposée d'une
majorité mais cette majorité est dite
relative c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne permet
pas d'atteindre le nombre de voix
nécessaire pour passer dans tous les cas
et dans toutes les situations tous les
textes que nous voudrions ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on va travailler
texte par texte la main elle est tendue
avec bienveillance avec l'envie absolue
de réformer notre pays en rappelant que
les Français se sont exprimés à quatre
reprises de vote pour les élections
présidentielles deux votes pour les
élections législatives et qu'ils ont
plébiscité en tout cas accordé leur
confiance au projet présenté par le
Président de la République et par la
majorité présidentielle donc ce projet
nous voulons le mettre en œuvre et nous
voulons le mettre en œuvre avec les
conditions qui sont celles d'une
majorité relative c'est-à-dire en
travaillant avec les oppositions
lorsqu'elles sont constructives et
qu'elles souhaitent avancer nous avons
fait un décompte a priori du nombre de
voix que la première ministre aurait été
sûr de recueillir en cas de vote de
confiance nous ne sommes pas certains
que les conditions de cette confiance a
priori auraient été réunies c'est
pourquoi que je le redis nous
travaillerons texte par texte dans la
durée pour pouvoir réformer le pays
[Musique]